migrants on board this tiny dinghy
paddled desperately away from france
a french maritime vehicle following
closely behind it escorting
possibly towards dover
earlier in the day several more tightly
packed rescue boats arrived at the port
of dover
with around 100 people on board among
them
were children there's been a significant
rise in the number of migrants and
refugees crossing the channel
this year alone 2 000 people have made
that journey
that's three times higher than last year
these are people
who have already been through terrible
things and they're people that we know
and that we talk to
seeing them having to risk their lives
like this is very very distressing
they try to deter them but the
deterrents don't work because the things
that they are running from
don't go away and they simply can't go
back being a refugee literally means
that to go back can mean death
so they can't go back they can't stay
they have no other choice apart from to
try and come
the government has recently announced
changes to the asylum process
it will mean that people who have paid a
people smuggler
or have come through what the government
deems as a safe country
will find it incredibly hard to claim
asylum in the uk
that's been criticized by rights groups
but the home office says the intention
is to make the system fairer
one thing is abundantly clear there are
still
many people who are willing or feel that
they have no choice but to make this
perilous journey
jemima walker sky news dover